today we'll be introduced with the
deaths of the Lancers Jaime Tyrion and
Cersei some of these deaths are
confirmed by a hundred percent energy
leaks and leaked photos while some are
only supported by theories of mine so
let's just jump into it let's start with
the death of Jaime Lannister whose end
will be no other than his sister and
former lover herself Cersei Lannister in
the end of season 7 Jaime finally sees
his sister for what she really is an
insane delusional and power-hungry queen
who will betray anyone to secure her
reign no matter if your own life or the
whole realm is in danger Jamie finally
Benison sister to honor and help The
North Face the White Walkers after he
learned deserts in urine plot to
dishonor the choose between the Iron
Throne and the Alliance of House
Targaryen and how start Jamie now rides
north but he will eventually be back at
King's Landing where he'll face death
queen and sacrificed his life for the
greater good just as every Knight should
just as he already did it by killing the
Mad King Jaime's riding north to fight
the army of the Dead but then he'll
arrive back to the south to fight
against both the army of the Dead and
Cersei he might be a bit confused right
now and that's okay give me a moment
explain it let me summarize Jamie's fate
in the final season until his very
bittersweet end in the beginning of
season a Jim still rides north toward
the river lands there he reunites with
Bronn and takes charge of the lynnster
forces that were deployed in the
Riverlands to ensure peace he then leads
his forces to Winterfell where he
reunites with his brother Tyrion Brienne
and all the others Jaime will
participate in a huge battle for
Winterfell in episode 3 in which the
living under John and Dana's command
will face a huge defeat how Starks
hereditary home will be destroyed they
will take severe casualties and some of
the main characters swim in there and
Jaime will survive let me also highlight
that there's a big mystery surrounding
the already infamous 3rd episode of the
final season that will be directed by
the same guy who directed the Battle of
the bastards there are few leaked photos
are supporting a possibility of the
living emerging victorious against the
army of the Dead but it will be sir
senior graduate that will destroy
Winterfell
basically this possibility John and
Dana's forces would face the army of the
dead at Winterfell and emerge victorious
but in massive casualties and no it
doesn't mean that living the fear in the
night king they justified it is current
army while his for me a new stronger and
larger army in the far south yell
thought that great 4 will be fought in
the north on the front defined by the
advancing army of the dead and partly we
are correct the north will face a
hundred thousand strong army of whites
led by the White Walkers by the night
King will not be there he will fly
zarion to the far south across Silvestro
sand will raise the dead does the entire
continent will be facing a horde of
White's overnight now you might be
wondering how is this
confirmed by give me a few moments
explained to you while prophesies in
game of journals don't literally come
true visions on the other hand do
involve brains vision of the exploding
wildfire already came true in season six
there are two more visions from the
future they're yet to come true it's the
shadow of a dragon flying over King's
Landing and the one image brain sees
King's Landing in winter with an empty
throne room that has its roof blown off
at first glance this would imply that
Danny doesn't up reaching and taking
over King's Landing eventually but the
crumpled building the Red Keep and burn
houses with the wintry background are of
the major importance then he would not
destroy the red cape in Michigan turn is
nor would she burn down houses for
innocent people live as proven in
numerous season seven scenes the damage
done to the Red Keep and to the house is
however is consistent with something
that Danish dragons would be able to do
the main suspect being her dead dragon
is Aryan this brains vision Spanish
Danny had as well along with Lake Forest
in which we can see that big portion of
King's Landing will at some point be
burned down pretty much confirm my
statement that night King will fly
bazarian to the far south and raise the
dead across solo Westeros although your
White Walkers is forming an army across
all Westeros his current army that has
in season seven finale finally crossed
it a Northville in the season 8 premiere
hit and destroyed castles of house amber
and health scar Stark
just as John in the season 7 premiere
said they would if the ball falls
basically the night King will create a
huge army in the south while sacrificing
his current army in the north anyways
after the battle is over after the
living has gone against a hundred
thousand strong army of the Dead at that
very moment urine appears for the
Ironborn delay inserts ended the golden
company he's been waiting for the battle
between the living and the dead to end
is their answers his orders to kill
what's left of the veining army you're
an attacking Winterfell once the battle
between living in the dead ends to kill
what's left of the victorious parties
coming as a huge surprise but at the
same time it's also kind of been
confirmed by League for us in these
leaked photos that were taken home
interval set we can see the dead
Ironborn that would be on schedule T's
in this battle of interval there's even
a leaked photo jam being taken hostage
to King's Landing supporting this
possibility even more as it seems soon
managed to imprison John that is shown
in this scene will take place in episode
4 as the director that episode was seen
on set
there is just one episode after the huge
battle for Winterfell super-nice
possibility of urine Teyana hostage even
more after all this turn of events might
not be that big of a surprise inserts
yourself said that she's going to use
urine graduate the golden company and
her armies to attack the victorious army
after the battle is over however one is
turn either dead or delivering
themselves will destroy Winterfell but
Jaime as well as
the main characters will not face their
end just yet now we're coming to the
long-anticipated Circe's downfall in
death they'll be caused by her becoming
the Met Queen
but unfortunately sir still not the end
for herself but for Jaime as well upon
suffering the tremendous defeat at
Winterfell and upon losing Jon Snow to
yearn and Cersei Dany and the crew will
retreat south Twitter the Riverlands or
the Bell
however devil then learned that the
night king has formed an even bigger
army of the dead in the South brain
starkville informed them that the
nineteen is marching his new army on
King's Landing King's Landing is the
largest city with a population of 1
million people and therefore they cannot
allow the night king to take it because
it would mean the end for living Ottoman
characters being an insulating at some
point of the final season has been
confirmed by the league for us as well
even though the entire living side is
coming to Circe's aid she's preparing a
trap for them Circe intends to have all
her enemies both the living and the dead
to fight on streets of King's Landing
while she would use wildfire to burn
them all search his plan is to wait in
the red cape for the army of the Dead to
bridge the city walls and for the great
battle to take place inside a capital
Cersei wouldn't burn all or enemies the
living in the dead using wildfire will
search he managed to pull it out and
burn everyone down even though burned
King's Landing set would seem to support
his theory the answer is no the Wildfire
is not the reason King's Landing set is
being burned down its jag on fire the
show build the King's Landing said
mainly to duel I power techniques
meaning that some parts of the capital
will be burned down by a dragon national
firing Game of Thrones is portrayed by
live pyrotechnics basically search is
planned to help the living and the dead
fighting style King's Landing will come
true but you're burning them all with
wildfire will not who will stop her even
though this part is not confirmed by
leaked photos I think it's safe to say
that the one to stop Cersei from burning
down the entire capital is Jaime
Lannister
Jaime already did a huge sacrifice in
order to save hundreds of thousands of
innocent lives by killing the Mad King
and has ever since been called the
King's lair to his irritation
however searchable now intend to do the
same throughout the show we learned that
the scar Jaime carries from his decision
to kill King Aerys Targaryen run deep
and Jamie's a man desperate to forge his
own legacy not to be remembered as the
Kingslayer
Jaime will do noble sacrifice once again
but this time he will not sacrifice his
honor this time it requires his life
Jamie's going to kill his sister once
she gives an order to Qyburn - as the
Mad King used to say burn them all Jaime
will sacrifice himself by killing Cersei
as the mountain will kill him
immediately
Jaime will kill the ruler of the Seven
Kingdoms once again but this time people
will not mock his name this time every
we'll know that Jamie Lannister is the
savior of the city and the only reason
they're alive his name will be
remembered as a hero and his great deed
will fulfill his empty pages in the
famous book of brothers his death will
probably be avenged by the Hound we
bring help how I see it happening is the
central gain and Brienne arriving at the
turn room just at the time to see the
mountains striking down Jaime the
fountain battles the mountain in epical
game ball while Jaime dies in Britain's
arms how do you want to go this Jaime's
end might have been foreshadowed by Lady
Olenna Tyrell and her last words but
your sister has done things I was
incapable of imagining you loved her you
really do love her you she'll be the end
of you possibly the last Lannister at
this point Tyrion is also going to die
his death has been confirmed by the same
source that leaked the entire season 7
the source is freaky doctor whose
channel you can visit by clicking the
link in the description down below last
year this guy shared the entire season 7
plot claiming it's legit leaks and as
most of you know it turned out accurate
Tyrion will apparently be judged as the
dragon Peyton shortly after executed
details freaky doctor says that in the
charge of a trial is certain that was he
worth accompanying with all the Starks
sensory and brain they're also similarly
brain tart Robin Arryn and two new
characters one of them wearing a golden
armor great worn with the unsullied will
also be there with a group of the
unsullied guarding Tyrion Lannister
Tyrion is being on trial for between
Daniel's family
freaky doctor says that bran stark will
use his greenside powers during this
trial and take us back to the first
season Britain recalls something Turner
said to his mother Catelyn Stark in the
first season
it's Tyrion statement that he would
never bet against his family there's
another thing we know Turner will say
they deserve it
implying that the people of King's
Landing deserve to die Tyrion is full of
anger the most dramatic moment of the
trial will be Tyrion falling on his
knees in the middle of a speech
dragged down by his actions he will also
not be able to ask for a child by combat
Fricke doctor doesn't know how he will
be executed because unlike the trial his
death was not filmed in Seville but in
the studio he also mentions that there
will not be much of a snow at the dragon
pit as most of it already melted down at
this point of the season meaning that
winter is most likely over by the time
Tyrion is being under trial ok during
the trader is being judged for it in a
game of turns finale he's betrayed a
knee in his side of it
but how is it possible one my ask well
in truth it so be happening before our
eyes
turns been fighting for Housley insert
or the entire season seven and we've all
witnessed it because of Tyrion in his
warplanes Dany has lost most of her
allies and her strength has drastically
decreased due to Tyrion and his planes
Dany has lost Dorne and the Aran Islands
- urine and Cersei during strategy to
take history Rock was a disaster as well
the unsullied took the fortress but the
forces was severely undermanned as most
of the Lannister garrison has left the
castle and attacked Highgarden
destroying another Denny's away and
taking all the food and gold Tyrion was
basically dead by his brother Jaime
Lannister all these turns plains
resulted with the food and the gold
being unprotected and basically for
Cersei to take it which she did
Tyrion explains also resulted it an
opportunity for Cersei to wipe out most
of the anisa lights which she did as
well the final war plan Tyrion head for
Dany was to bring the dead to Cersei
Lannister to in her sport this resulted
with the death of a dragon and it Circe
is still not willing to support the
living is it possible that earrings
being outsmarted by Cersei and Jaime
even though he is said to be the
smartest Lannister is it a coincidence
that all Tyrians plans made more damage
than good for Danny
Tyrion whose vet intellect and keen mind
for strategy was seemingly without peer
right at Westeros as Danny's hand with
one of the greatest armies that Westeros
has ever seen if he bonito Tyrion could
have secured the throne for Dany and may
her army stronger than ever
but he did just the opposite and with
the purpose to make his family the most
powerful once again long story short the
only way for Cersei and Jaime to appear
as the winning side against deserts what
if Tyrion was still fighting for his
family if he decided to spare their
lives
did he really believed Cersei when she
said that she'll send help north to aid
a living in the great war against the
night king the answer is no as a matter
of fact Cersei Interior and made
together this decision let me explain
how they took place in the season 7
finale is opening moments Justin was
presented with an opportunity to earn a
promise of peace from Cersei instead
chooses to remain loyal to Danny Tyrion
in particular was upset with John
explaining that sometimes there's a
value in telling someone you'll give
them what they want even if you do not
plan on actually doing so which is
executor Tyrion and Cersei did later in
that episode
it's RC promising to aid them in the
great war throughout the meeting Tyrion
even confess that he's the one
preventing House Lannister from falling
you've convinced about down before I
know was working towards the same goal
the gum you've worked towards your
entire see I didn't know attraction at
this family I am the warden preventing
that from happening
Daenerys didn't want to debate and
negotiate she didn't want to bring new
words she wanted to bring you fire and
blood until I advised her otherwise I
don't want to destroy our family I never
have dearly smart and all the plans he
made his soul through them and he saw
the outcome everything he did he did
rivet a purpose and that's to prevent
House Lannister from falling to make it
stronger anyways after professing his
love for services disease children and
realizing his sister was pregnant even
Sultan's just before the camera cuts
away from the scene altogether the next
time we see two characters is during the
return to the dragon pit
Cersei suddenly willing to help John and
Danny in their battle against the White
Walkers so to be clear Tyrion said to
read people and their intention as
easily as he reads books which has been
proven right multiple times throughout
the show but he fails to read her Cersei
he fails to read reserves his intention
and believes her civil send help
Tyrion and Cersei most likely made a
deal under meeting exactly when the
camera cut away and it's Tyrion who told
her story with John and Danny and who
promised them the help in the wars to
come
Tino's new plan is to put Cersei and
Jamie's child on the Iron Throne
Tyrion cut a deal with Cersei he know
she was not going to go north and he
told her to lie about it basically
Tyrion works for the best of its family
and it will most likely be exposed by
brain and his visions